[Music]
what's going on guys my name is James
I'm Mitch and welcome back to the
channel today we're going to be looking
at all the different google home
products before we get started I just
wanted to thank everybody that
subscribed so far last week after the
Monday upload we made it to 100
subscribers which I know isn't a lot but
for a little guy like me that's only
been on YouTube for two months now it's
a big deal and slowly we're growing
every single day so thank you for
joining the community thank you for
following along let's get into this
review chances are if you're watching
this video you're thinking about getting
one of these Google home minis for
yourself or for somebody's a gift I know
over the years I've definitely given out
a couple of these as gifts to the people
I love and two close friends and family
because well they're a fantastic little
gift and at the moment in Australia you
can pick them up for under $50 if you're
watching this video in America or just
want an American Standard is a reference
I think that's about 30 USD or something
close to that so they're incredibly
cheap at the moment especially with the
end of financial year sales here and
show though the real question here is is
it worth spending your money on this
little device or even the full-size
Google home is it going to be useful in
your day to day life and really is it
just a good speaker to have well I'm
going to try to break it down into five
different categories and five reasons
why I personally think that this speaker
is fantastic and worth your money today
in 2019 so the number one reason to
purchase Google home Mini is the fact
that it is a hands-free search bar
chances are you're not going to use it
that much but you will use it every now
and again
I don't know frequently ask Google
what's the weather like in the morning
to make sure I address appropriately for
the day I also ask it how long to work
and things like that
the second reason I'd recommend buying
one of these is the fact that it's a
hands-free calculator now no that's a
bit of a weird one to bring up in a top
five video but for my situation is
something that I use quite a lot if I'm
sitting on my laptop doing some econ
work I can easily just go what's ten
plus ten or
what's fifty seven times thirty-two and
it's gonna give me an answer straight
away the third reason to buy one of
these little devices is the fact that
it's super helpful and convenient with
now if you're somebody like me that's
always thinking about different things
and getting a random thoughts in the
middle of the night and when you're too
far from your phone or too far from a
notepad to write it down you can always
just say remind me to take out the trash
tonight at 6:00 p.m. or remind me to
pick up the washing from the laundry at
5:00 p.m. you can really tell it to do
anything and we're going straight to
your phone if you've set it up correctly
now talking about the setup of Google it
is very simple and quick to do and
there's a million tutorials on YouTube
so I won't do one of them but if you're
not tech savvy or if you are tech savvy
regardless of the fact it is very simple
to set up
you do need a smart phone though to make
it work and a good Wi-Fi connection so
make sure you have both of those before
you go out and buy one of these little
speakers the fourth reason why these
little speakers are great and I guess
it's something that Google is doing to
kind of encourage you to purchase more
and more of their products is the fact
that you can tell it to stream anything
to your TV or to a chromecast now we've
purchased a chromecast for our house
we've got it plugged into the TV so we
can always just go play something on
Netflix and it's gonna play whatever we
decide most of the time it's something
like I don't know the Fresh Prince of
bel-air
shoutout to Lou Smith but yeah the
Google Homes linked with the Google home
ultras
fantastic little things that you can
really link up and sync up and they're
great if you're sitting on your laptop
want to cast your screen to the TV I
don't know show some documents show some
different photos you can really share
the whole experience with the family
which is great if you don't have a smart
TV already now I'm going to break the
rules here and my fifth point of action
is actually going to be a negative one
in Australia at least so far in
Australia you can't make phone calls or
send text messages through the Google
home or the Google home Mini
unfortunately this is a feature that is
slowly being rolled out into the US but
it hasn't made it to Australia yet and
20
which is a bit of a chop ball but it
will eventually come through which I'm
looking forward to because telling
Google to quickly send a message to
anybody will be super convenient when
you're too far from your phone or busy
doing something potentially even you're
cutting chicken or making some food and
your hands are full so basically having
a remote speaker in your house which is
a phone accessory will be a great
addition to any household and make it a
budget smart home for under 50 bucks and
there you have it guys that's my review
of the Google home and the Google home
Mini if you enjoyed this video make sure
you smash that subscribe button
20:19 style I'm releasing a new video
every single Monday on different tech
and e-commerce advice so if you have an
interest in any of those things I'll see
you next Monday what's the weather like
currently 20 and clear on Saturday it'll
be mostly sunny with a high of 26 and a
low of 16